He's like a pariah in the Warhammer 40K universe. He actually
he has no former substance. He's kind of like a demon. And I
agree with that. But at the same time, the these
You can't predict anything about this person. And you know what
I think what about a person I can't predict anything about who's
shown a propensity for lying and changing their stripes at the
drop of a hat? MAKE THAT MAN PRESIDENT. MAKE THAT MAN president
now.
The context that we would miss, I think, is something along these
lines, okay? Basically, Connor and Pisco had a conversation about
why Connor would vote for J.D. Vance and not someone like Mondani,
right? And Connor basically had no solid idea of why he would
do that. He He rattled off a few things, right? He rattled off
a few things, but he had no solid reasoning for why he would
do one or the other. He had no solid reason for why he liked
or believed in J.D. Vance in any way. And Pisco was kind of poking
at him a little bit. And then I believe with this conversation
it gets a little more direct. A little more direct.
And basically in both of these conversations, Connor is basically
like, I just want space fascism. I just want space fascism more
than anything in the
Make me a space marine. Get us to space. I just want my my novels
to be reality. Sort of like the political advocacy he engages
in, okay?
I'm trying to think if there's something else. It's realistically
Oh, I think it might I can't remember which conversation it is
now cuz I've watched a little bit of all three. I actually watched
the whole first one. But the statement I remember is
when J.D. Vance said something about being post-liberal, I was
shocked. I was shocked that J.D. Vance defined himself as a post-liberal.
And it's like, brother, the thing I the thing he got on my radar
for, like in a big way, okay? There's the Peter Thiel stuff,
sure. Commander Trump, thank you for the four months. There's
the Peter Thiel stuff,
But the thing that like really threw me off about him was when
he kept citing when they're talking about rage
remove retire all government government employees, yes. When
they're talking about that, he's people were saying like, I don't
know if that'll be constitutional. He said, "Well, I like I like
the Andrew Jackson quote on this. You know, the Chief Justice
has made his ruling, now let him enforce it." Implying that all
enforcement, okay? This is by the way, go back to Andrew Wilson's
talk about how force is power. All the monopoly on violence is
what gives you power. Well, guess who controls the military?
Guess who controls the National Guard? Guess who controls a ton
of stuff in Washington. It's all the president, okay? The president
is the person who controls
Therefore, force. Therefore, the president has the real power.
So, when Andrew Jackson says, "The Chief Justice has laid down
his ruling, now let him enforce it." That's him saying, "We have
the power and we don't have to listen to the Supreme Court."
It's him announcing, before they even started governing, that
they would not have to listen to the Supreme Court. And then
Connor goes, "Oh, it really shocked me when J.D. Vance seemed
like he didn't want to follow Republican values. It really shocked
me when he seemed like he didn't want to follow the rule of law.
It really shocked me when he seemed like he was not really like
into democracy."
How? He transparently telegraphed it a hundred different times.
How? How? How? HOW COULD YOU THINK THIS?
You're a complete [__] [__]
Okay, anyway, so we from there, that's where we pick it up. I
think we are going to skip this one though. Now, as a teaser,
apparently Connor went after Pisco's Pisco's girlfriend.
Somewhere around here.
Send a description of sense. I don't think I'm self-aware enough
to know whether or not that's true. I'm I'm just fighting for
what I think is true. I would say that if I was bringing up a
criticism of you, I think that because you are friends with leftists,
you run a podcast with a leftist, you are dating dating Are are
you still with Joe? Yeah.
Isn't Joe a socialist?
Why does this matter? I don't think she'd identify as that. >> Because
I think you have a blind spot because you believe these people
are good people. Okay.
Okay. I'm just going to take this on its face and keep watching.
I'm sorry to >> they're well-intentioned.
And and they're and they're part of your coalition because they'll
vote the right
But I I think you have a blind spot for them. Be- because you
don't view socialism as bad as I You don't You don't view socialism
as bad as fascism. Do Pisco and Straight Rage still do a podcast,
by the way? When was the last time they did the the Pisco Straight
Rage thing?
When was the last time that stream happened? I feel like that's
like looking at a month ago now, no? >> So, you're willing
to tolerate good
in your life and in your professional sphere. And if anybody
says, "Hey, I view fascism and socialism as
like ideologies that are effectively two sides of the same coin."
You can be dismissive of it because you know good people. And
the good people are going to vote with you. And arguably, they're
a larger part of
Okay, I don't Okay, whatever. That was
I mean, it's it's accusing Pisco of a
So, you should be able to articulate the bias. It's like, oh,
you give them too much charity. It's like, okay, well, I give
every How would you argue against I give everybody charity?
And how in the world could you possibly say that I give more
to these people? Like, where is the where is the element that
more exists other than I disagree with you? Like, you're saying
I'm biased, but you can't say where my analysis is wrong. You
consistently get gated open in all of these conversations, right?
Consistently.
Why is that the case if I'm wrong? Why is that the case if you're
right? Shouldn't Shouldn't this like bias lead to some some element
of like failure on my part where I'm incorrect and you win the
Shouldn't that happen? Connor shows up.
Connor doing the classic he got a chart, okay? Connor's got a
chart. He's here with the chart. Let's go.
Connor has a chart. He's
ready to explain his ideas finally with visual guides. So, as
an example,
Obama Oh, hold on. >> Pisco says hi. Oh. Hi.
All right. So, it felt like in our previous conversation. We
don't have to have a long conversation, by the way. I just wanted
to drop by cuz I mostly drew this because of our conversation.
Um so, I listed a series of of criteria that I'm evaluating people
on for potential potentially being president of the United States.
And if you look at it, Oh my god. Sorry. Yes. Sorry, that was
an instant
That's fine. Um intelligence, cunning, neoconservatism, which
you could just see you see like turn into geopolitical in How
is Hasan a zero on everything? Mondani's almost a zero on every
Mondani's a 10 on intelligent, a 10 on cunning. >> intelligence,
constitutional loyalty, social conservatism, fiscal conservatism,
national conservatism,
Hold on. Hold on. Hold on. which you could just see see like
turn into geopolitical intelligence,
constitutional loyalty, social conservatism, fiscal conservatism,
national conservatism, Burkean
And of course, we could come up with like more criteria and weight
them
Uh however, I went through like a series of characters and I
evaluated them on a scale of one to 10 and I added up their total
number from a scale of 80. Oh, [__] All right. This
totally This is totally insane.
Nikki Haley is clearly Israel first and he has her as a 10 on
national conservatism. Are you out of your mind? Yeah. And so,
when we're And this is kind of how because it felt like in our
previous conversation,
uh because the the you were weighting them differently, I suppose.
Um but also you thought that some categories should override
other categories or whatever. We just like jumped from category
to category, which I think is why the conversation was like all
over the place. Whereas if you actually look at the evaluative
criteria,
pretty much everybody ranks in where approximately I think they
would rank. So, as an example,
Obama
is better than way better than Trump, way better than Harris,
way better than Vance. But then in my evaluative criteria, Vance
and Harris are competitive, but Harris is better.
Weirdly enough, Newsom is better than
But then I brought up how if Newsom panders to Mondani and Hasan
[__] he could drop his scores. And I brought up how
Vance could bring up his scores.
Is Did Connor do this like on stream? He had to have, right?
Cuz otherwise, he sounds like he was just talking to himself.
And I just hope that's not the case. And then I also did Hasan
[__] the Bush family, Teddy Roosevelt,
Lincoln, Haley, who scored the highest in my opinion.
Ron,
Joe Biden.
And so, within this criteria stuff, >> Ron DeSantis?
Yeah. Okay.
Um so, so within this like evaluative criteria, we could argue
about like the the scores that I gave people and why.
But it I think this is This is what you're thinking about. These
are the things you're thinking
Yeah. It It kind of Hey, if Hasan's a zero on intelligence is
a and a zero on cunning, then how can you say he's hiding his
beliefs at all? Why is there any like question about his beliefs
to anybody? Or would Connor just use that to go, "There isn't
a question amongst anybody intelligent." I I try to make clear
the criteria through which I'm evaluating people and why I'm
ranking them the way that I'm ranking them. Lazy ass. Okay.
Okay, that's that's helping me understand.
And um before I tear into this a little bit, and that is always
my nature is just like tearing into stuff. And so, don't take
it personally.
And we'll definitely get in the weeds on some of this stuff cuz
this is triggering me just looking at it a little bit. But just
to make sure before I start doing that, I'm trying to recognize
myself. Um, you're weighing all of these different attributes
equally. So, you someone who is zero on constitution,
you that the the points for constitution
are just as much weighted as the points for Burkean conservatism
or intelligence,
For the sake of simplicity, yeah. Okay.
Um, all right. And
This this kind of thing you you like do this when you're a kid
and then you realize that it's like totally inefficient and ineffective.
It's like Connor's like
Connor's like has the mind of like a 15-year-old. I feel like
when I was 14 or 15 I used to do this with things. I'd make like
a little metric and I'd like make a little formula that you get
out together and and try to score things and then you realize
it just doesn't work. It's like too complicated and then
like legit my Naruto power scaling book. Dude, I did a Dragon
Ball Z site when I >> This is how I understand you. Tell
me if it's right.
As as opposed to intelligence, it's kind >> me. Um, willingness
to be ruthlessly
cutthroat and pragmatic.
Is that what you mean by cunning? Uh, I would say like a combination
of like charisma and political maneuvering.
Okay, charisma and political maneuvering. Okay. Okay, I buy that.
Um, and social meaning social policy?
Uh, I would say that this would be social conservatism. I kind
of rooted it in like conservative philosophy.
Uh, weirdly enough, being higher on the social conservative ladder
might actually be bad um, because
it's effectively like how pro-gay and how pro-minority are you,
I suppose. Uh, but then I tried to like weight it back um, where
Oh, that is really funny though that he decided to do this whole
thing and then he didn't have the foresight to just put it in
a spreadsheet. He used paint. He built a grid in paint. He didn't
go to like
He just went to paint. Effectively like >> So, a 10 isn't
most conservative. A 10 is like the ideal social policy, right?
So, 10 is like the ideal social policy, which isn't which is
like your vision of what is the correct thing to do, right? Probably
the the balance. Yeah, I guess if I probably flubbed this category
on an evaluative criteria, but if I was to try to like make it
as strong as I possibly could, it would be the balance between
being too progressive and being too conservative.
Got it. So, in other words, I just don't want people to get the
wrong impression. It's like intelligence on the intelligence
score, more intelligence is better and 10 is maximum, you know,
comparative intelligence, right? 10 being the maximum. And but
but that's not necessarily the case for things like neocon and
social and fiscal, where I'm assuming by fiscal you don't mean
it's like the ideal fiscal policy and social is the ideal social
policy, not just necessarily 10 equals the most possible social
conservatism, right? Because I was waking up and getting caffeinated,
I probably mixed some of my categories in that regard. So, I
might
Okay, let's be real. Some people watch this. You told me you
you watch this,
We don't actually evaluate this chart for very long, do we? We
get to a conversation where this chart no longer becomes relevant.
Can we
can we just go and do like
can we please can we we don't have to
we don't have to do this, right?
We need the chart on Pisco's request. I Dude, like graded people
on how much they actually like executed that ideal versus like
whether or not they maximally fulfilled the ideology, I suppose.
So, I might have mixed those, but I agree with you that Dude,
why did Pisco so passive-aggressive?
Pisco so passive OH MY GOD.
DUDE, HE had to click on that to highlight it. He had to click
on that to highlight it. He's so Dude, he hates these people
so much. You know it cuz
here's the thing. Connor is Rage Pope, but infinitely less intelligent.
And Pisco Just go look at how Pisco used to treat Rage Pope in
like DGG stream
He's far less intelligent than Rage Pope, but he takes the same
positions.
Bro, Pisco is holding himself back so hard in every conversation
he has with Connor trying not to treat him like a total slobbering
[__] It's crazy. mixed those, but I agree with you
that What I mean to say is one and stuck with it. >> Unlike
intelligence and cunning, which are like over your
your your 10 is going to be like maximum cunning, right? And
intelligence is maximum intelligence, whatever reasonable maximum
is. I'm not even saying that it's like the biological limit or
anything. All I'm just saying is those are ranked in terms of
the greater the better, but some of these other scores aren't
ranked greater the better. It's like closest proximity to ideal,
right? And 10, what does it represent? The most conservative
for social, it's 10 is the most ideal
for social policy or something like >> Yeah, let's roll
with that, but truth be told, as an example,
uh, Teddy Roosevelt with uh, social
How far do we go before this is off the screen? It's on the screen
the whole
Okay, there's just no There's no way they're really discussing
this for this long, right? 3 hours of talking about this chart.
>> social conservatism,
I put him at a 10,
uh, which is probably not an evaluation of an ideal. That's actually
probably
I'll be real. I'll be real. I'm I'm trying to think of any way
of getting out of this right now. I'm I'm sorry. >> evaluating
them by modern standards. These are all relative to Okay, to
their
Okay, to their times. >> Yeah, so I so I probably I probably
[__] that up a little bit, where in some circumstances
I was scaling them on ideal and in some circumstances I was scaling
them on adherence to ideology. So, I could rework some of these
numbers, but I still think just as like a conversation starter,
uh, this is it's it's at least it formalizes what we should be
evaluating. I I I get it. I get it. Um, and we can definitely
speak more in like the concept you're trying to convey to me
as opposed to the specifics here, but just so people understand
who are watching, I think that what that means is you wouldn't
say Teddy Roosevelt has your ideal social policy because Teddy
Roosevelt, of course, was a raging racist, right? By our standards.
By that By those standards, right? Relatively progressive and
modern, but by our standards >> weirdly enough, yeah, weirdly
enough I would probably Maybe I would like bump him down to like
a seven or something like that, because he was a raging racist,
but he was also like a civic nationalist. So, he might be like,
"Oh, the the the black skull shape is more prone to criminality,
but if they love America, they can be great Americans." You know?
So, it would be it'd be pretty racist, but it would also be like
incredibly civic nationalist.
But wouldn't civic Connor is also adding in all of the elements
here.
literally the only thing he could be mad at Fuentes for is anti
is is anti-Zionism, right? If he's If he's like, "Oh, well, civic
nationalism, you know, if you're if you're like, oh, all I don't
care about your race, even though I think even though I'm racist
and that's fine with him." If that's where he's coming from with
that, then
why what problem does he have with Fuentes? Just that Fuentes
doesn't like
Why would that be a problem? >> nationalism be subsumed
under nation
as opposed to social?
maybe, but then I use that category for national conservatism
because effectively I'm I'm evaluating these people under Oh,
hold on. Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. No, it's that it's
that Fuentes would do like social spending. That's why. That's
why. >> Uh, conservative criteria and weirdly enough, uh,
Trump and Vance are 100% maxed out on national conservatism because
they're obsessed And I don't understand that.
Yeah, their their their obsession.
Looks like a lot of people are Somehow Bush was maxed out on
national conservatism. I don't understand that. Teddy, Lincoln,
Haley, I This is this column makes no [__] sense.
He just gave everybody 10s here. This is I can tell what this
is. This is Connor is Everything about Connor says he's a neocon,
but he wants to say he's like a civic nationalist,
but realistically all the people he hates are actual nationalists.
And all the people he he people he likes are just total neocons.
He's just decided that neocon and civic nationalist are the same
thing. It's like it's It's like the worst most transparent
is maintaining American demographics.
That's their obsession. >> That's national conservatism
is maintaining American demographics?
>> And and you're giving benefit to Trump for that? So,
the fact that he wants to maintain current racial demographics
and ethnic demographics Is Connor's disability that he like can't
say something then let it go? Like even if he realizes he said
something totally stupid that he's like, "Now I'm committed to
that." See, like Erudite, like, "Oh, I said something totally
[__] stupid, but
I said it on the internet, so now I need to stand on it no matter
what."
Like this is a shared philosophy it seems between both of them,
where they just shoot themselves in the foot repeatedly, over
and over and over
Okay. So, you get 10s. You've maxed out wanting to maintain demographics
in the United States. That means you want to maintain You want
whites to remain a majority in the United States, right, Connor?
That's what you mean? That's literally what you mean right now?
>> That is like a bonus that he's think he considering
that and trying to protect our racial and ethnic makeup. Well,
that that's what I'm saying where if we I would have to pick
one and stick with it, where I would either have to say I'm I'm
grading these people on adherence to the ideology
or I'm grading them on ideal policy. And truth be told, because
I was waking up and getting caffeinated, I think I flip-flopped
between the two of them.
I just don't understand Okay, I get that you were caffeinated
and
I really So, you're saying like it's positive to be like a white
nationalist?
And Connor's like, "Well, it's getting caffeinated, so I kind
of confused ideal and like ideal and ideology, you know? I kind
of confused them." Yeah, that's not what I asked. I'm saying
are you giving tens to white nationalists? Do you think with
Nikki Haley's a white nationalist? What what is happening? >> Also,
very it's a it's a very
Are whites the majority? I believe Whites are still the voting
majority. I believe just very, very, very barely the voting majority.
The issue is like new generations, like the 18 to 24 bracket
is not white majority, right? So, like as people die off, as
this population cliff hits, uh the the white majority is going
to disappear fast. I believe that's still the case though, right?
Hold on, let's check real quick so I ethnic makeup. I think it
might even be up at like 58, 59%. White Whites 60%.
I just saw it. White European, Middle Eastern, North African
Americans 61.6%
is still the
So, yeah, it's
Oh. Oh, this is 2020 census though for racial groups. So,
2025 data says 53%. I I would imagine some of that will get broken
out. I don't think in 5 years you've lost 8% of the white population
or something. Yeah, I got Tucker and Milo. Yeah, I got it. I
see it. >> at this. So, I I'm not mad that you made this.
I'm just perplexed. So, are you suggesting now or are you not
suggesting that someone who is trying to maintain the racial
and ethnic
demographic numbers of America, they would get a 10.
Like the Like if they were to to be incredibly focused on that,
they would benefited from it. Under this rubric, right? That
That would be the reason that you want to maintain the ethnic
and racial demographic Yeah. Connor, you could just say you made
a mistake. Connor, you could just say, "No, that's not the case."
Connor, you could just say, "No." Connor, you could just say
no if you want. Nobody's making you say this, Connor. Nobody's
making you take Nobody's making you step off this cliff. Nobody's
making you step off this cliff. Nobody's doing it. >> right
now. And that's an important point for you. Weirdly, um I would
probably take because this is something that we probably disagree
on, all right? I think we do disagree on it. Um I would probably
The Also, Pisco needs a producer desperately who can tell him
nobody gives a [__] about this chart in actuality.
You can like minimize it unless you're asking a question from
it directly. Okay? Put the camera's up. Don't just leave your
[__] chart up here. I don't give a [__]
Put the camera's up, Connor. Connor, I'm asking you. Do you get
Do you get
Give me a second. Okay, so the reason why Biden, [__]
and a few other people got like zeros or close to zeros on national
whatever is cuz in my opinion they don't give a [__]
about the border, right? They don't give a [__] about
demography. They want as many immigrants as possible, and I think
that's cringe, right? Uh-huh. Uh so, I I think I'm a civic nationalist.
I'm a paperwork nationalist. I think that we should have an extreme
vetting criteria
where you you basically should red, white, and blue >> race
neutral and and ethnicity neutral? Or not? >> It's It's
race neutral,
uh but it's civically very selective. Okay, then is it the case
that So, then my question stands, which is It's race neutral.
So, you said this had to do with maintaining like ethnic makeup.
So, when you did this, was it civic nationalism or was it something
else? Cuz you said maintaining ethnic makeup, and you gave tens
to people you think will do that. And it even doesn't make sense.
Like there's no reason to believe Bush would be a 10 for maintaining
the ethnic makeup of the United States. Like Yeah, it's so incoherent
that you can just get out of anything here, Connor. Please just
give me anything coherent to engage with. Do people who are ideologically
committed to preserving the racial and ethnic demographics of
America, would they be benefited under this nation criteria?
I think they would because if you if you compare it to open borders
advocates, I would I would rate them at a zero. Whereas if you
looked at uh Trump and Vance, let's say that because they weren't
civic nationalists, I bumped them down to like a seven or a six
because they're kind of not fulfilling my ideal. Um they would
still probably like I'm sure Trump and Vance would still make
accept I mean, Vance is married to a [__] Indian
woman. Trump fought his own base on H-1B visas. They would probably
be more aligned with if you're a different demographic, you when
you come here you have to put red, white, and blue.
Yeah, but it's >> they would probably get a benefit. Well,
I'm not saying >> not be a maximal benefit. >> saying
that incidentally could they people who you know, as a mirror
um
I don't think it's even bad to say you think maintaining the
ethnic makeup is important. I don't think that's even bad. But
Connor can't do that and like maintain the totally
like e-kind and and respectful relationships that he has with
some of the people he's friends with, right? He can't He can't
rift appropriately while being a civic nationalist who thinks
ethnic makeup of the United States is important. I think it's
totally fine to say, "Actually, I kind of don't want my people
to disappear from this country. I don't want to fall into a my
minority." I think that'd be bad. I don't have a problem with
people saying that, but a lot of people do.
So, I I would just want Connor to say that that's what he believes.
He could say, "Oh, well, I don't think it's bad if people believe
that." He could say something else, but he's just not saying
>> correlation that that would happen. I'm asking, is the
criteria, does it benefit policies whose intent are to preserve
ethnic and racial demographics? Cuz you seem to suggest
that that was what was the the criteria was about. It was like
being very conscious of racial and ethnic lines, and that would
sort of imply / entail that that's something that you view as
preferable.
If not, then why don't you just change that to like immigration
or something, which is what one of my commenters are saying.
If if that's >> because I do put some weight there. So,
as an example, we we brought On race Please be clear. On race
and ethnicity,
Yeah, so ethnicity
ethnicity
I don't value that as a solitary category because every time
that you try to isolate ethnicity,
um it kind of doesn't work. What what I what I use in difference
is like
And then same thing with like racial. Like like I don't think
I give a [__] about racial, right? So, but I do care
about
Try to I thought Connor streams on his own. What happens when
Pisco isn't like holding this guy down, tying him down like he's
a [__]
a totally terrified patient at the dentist. Like he is strapped
down to a bed, and Pisco's like extracting teeth in the most
painful process possible to get him to be coherent in any way.
How the [__] does he talk by himself?
Where What happens on the regular stream where Connor is by himself?
Pisco is like fighting He He's like Neo fighting all the Agent
Smiths in the middle of that courtyard just trying to get Connor
to make any amount of sense to anybody, and it's nearly impossible,
but he's doing it through heroic
effort. Like I
>> is happening? And so,
when it comes to national conservatism,
I think that we could take probably a [__] Muslims.
Maybe hundreds of thousands, maybe millions. But, they would
need to be American civic nationalist, and they would need to
be moderate in their religion. And so, therefore, like this is
a screening criteria that I care about.
I do think that we should screen for and I also would not want
like a Muslim majority. Like Hey, how do you screen How do you
screen people coming in who are willing to lie to you?
First question. Excuse me, um are you suggesting you like pet
scan everybody who comes into the country? Do you like check
to see if they're lying? You do I You're He's literally like
we have to mind read people.
We have to mind read Muslims, the people with the doctrine apparently,
according to Connor and other people, that says they can just
lie about the religion to to escape persecution.
Like if we took We're currently at 330 million people. If we
had an opportunity to take another 200 million Muslims into the
United States, and we just had all of the infrastructure available
to do it, I would say no. I would say that's a bad idea.
So, to what extent do you agree with the following statement,
and then we'll get back to the rubric. It is important to me
to preserve the white character of America.
Like a three out of 10. So, you somewhat agree with aspects of
that that America there should be some consideration of
That's fine. I If people want to soy about that, that's stupid.
All the great Americans in all of history are white. To not to
get rid of America's white character entirely or something would
it wouldn't make any sense, okay? Just doesn't make any sense.
>> America is a white country.
In my my opinion, we should preserve it as like a a plurality.
A a Northern European plurality.
Got it. Let's get into the rubric. >> So, we're at we're
at 30% of Oh, wait. Hold on.
No, he's just Wait.
That's not what three out of 10 means. That's not what three
out of 10 means at all. He's like, "Oh, no. Like together, whites
should be the biggest coalition. It's pretty critical that whites
are the biggest coalition."
What?
That's totally different from what It's a three out of 10. I
just think we should make sure that like whites are the biggest
coalition. If they're not the plurality, then I think they're
probably bad. percent, but the other
Yeah. Yeah, no meds. No meds. Meds don't
Every one of these Every one of these
Nah.
Nah, get them out. Get them out of here. So, are the med 40%
is Hispanic, which is also a European colonial project. And then
if another 10 to 15% is black, and another 10 to 15% is Asian,
um I think we can uh we can power broker uh these ethno-religious
tribes, and hopefully eventually we evolve past
Wait, ethno-religious tribes? Does he know what an ethno-religion
is? uh these ethno-religious tribes, and hopefully eventually
we evolve past the ethno-religious tribalism. Right. Does he
Ethno-religion is a very specific term. Why is he He's just He's
saying that there are groups that have an
and a religion,
and so they're
He's not talking about Jews. He's not talking about Jews. He's
definitely not talking about Jews.
He means Muslim? Then he's stupid.
Muslims are not an ethno-religion. That's explicitly why it's
able to spread so far and wide, because they're not an ethno-religion
in any way. There's super chat that they paid me to read this
to you. Pisgo, here's $10 to tell Connor he made a very nice
list. Ethno Ethno-religion is not a a tribe. Sorry, ethno- The
ethno-religion is that people join the religion by joining the
That is how you get into the religion, right? Mus- uh Islam is
explicitly not an ethno-religion. They conquered people and they
converted them.
That is explicitly not an >> We're going to stop pretending
to care now. I don't agree with this. I actually do care and
I want to talk about it. Here's $10 to tell Connor he made a
very
That's that's >> to stop pretending to care now. I don't
agree with this. I actually do care and I want to talk about
it. Um on the >> Yeah, suck a dick, super chatter. So you
>> Lenny Lenny just a bunch of rabbits, okay? A bunch of
little bunnies. And George is saying they're like George is sitting
there and he's like getting He's trying to explain to Lenny why
it's bad. And somebody comes along and goes, "George, we need
to get to work. Stop spending time trying to explain to Lenny
why he's And George is like, "No, this is important so he doesn't
hurt people in the future. I have to help."
That's what just happened. >> But actually
someone who is completely race neutral >> Pisgo. Tell me
about the farm. Tell me about the farm, Pisgo. Tell me about
the farm again. >> neutral in their policy. He's not going
to be as good in the nation score as someone who is moderately
interested in preserving aspects of the white character of America,
correct? Someone who's totally race neutral will be worse off
>> you keep adding You keep adding white, but yeah. No,
but but you said but you're buying I'm putting it there. You
can reject it or accept it. I'm putting it there and asking,
"Do you accept it?" And you're saying, "Yes." So it So race Because
Because I kind of accept it because I think people presume when
you put
Save Save those bits for the face cam. I'll never be able to
do that voice with the face cam, because unfortunately that voice
is tied to a very very offensive face I make that like screw
I screw up my face to try to look as as possible while I do it.
I will never be able to do that on stream. It'll be incredibly
offensive. I'll get banned from Twitch for it. I can do the voice
by itself, but I do a face with the voice that would never be
acceptable to play company, okay? >> Like you care about
the white character of the United States of America or whatever,
they presume that that means that you're like hostile to ethno-religious
tribes or uh other ethno-religious or or racial tribes. Like
there's there's like a handful of real ethno-religions. Judaism
is one. I think Druze are another one. Um Whatever the Assad
family was, I forget what it I can't remember off the top of
my head. Why can't I remember what they Whatever they are is
another one. There's like only a handful of ethno-religions.
It's like It's like literally defined. Alawites. I think Alawites
are another
What do we got for ethno-religions?
Alawites, Amish, Cossacks, Doukhobors,
um ethno-religious fusion, Hutterites, Kalash, Mandaeans, Maronites,
Melkites, Molokans. Dude, these these people are all in a These
people are all in Syria, aren't they? Why is every ethno-religion
in Syria? What the [__] It's almost like it's the
the cradle of civilization or something. The hell? What the Okay,
uh Parsis, Saint Thomas Christians, Samaritans. Yeah, so it's
like these groups, okay?
Like These are the ethno-religions.
There aren't other ethno-religions, bro. There really aren't
that many ethnic religion. Okay, ethnic religion is a different
thing, okay? This is This might be something like what Connor's
referring to, that there are religions that do happen to be made
up or they're they're like ethnic makeup ethnically made up religions,
like specifically when you say the Russian Orthodox Church, right?
See, Orthodox Church that happens to have a large group that's
one ethnicity.
But that's That's not what any of these other groups are. And
that's not an ethno-religion. Ethno-religion is the religion
is spread via the bloodline, via the ethnicity. Baa. Baa. Baa.
>> know how to apply that, but but this is it is you are
stating that there's something important about our policy
You can convert to Judaism as well. I don't believe they even
consider you a real Jew at that point.
I'm pretty sure. Like converting to Judaism is incredibly difficult,
right? Like it's way more difficult than any other religion.
And And traditionally the only way that you become a Jew is you
have a Jew mother. Like You literally if you only have a Jew
father, I do not believe for a very long period of time they
consider you Jewish.
trying to preserve an aspect of the what whatever you want to
call white America.
Who is they?
Okay, yes or no? Is it not in Jew doctrine that you are only
Jew if you have a Jew mother?
The answer is yes. Stop arguing. Stop trying to be a nitpicking
white character of our our nation, the ethnic characters of our
nation, however you want to term that, that is conscious of people's
racial and ethnic makeups.
>> Uh add in religion, but yeah. Sure, we can add religion
in there as as one of the components. So So nation has to do
with like
the aspects of America
that are non-legal, right? It's not looking at the Constitution,
fair? That's you have a whole different thing for that. It's
not looking at It's looking at America
not in view of patriotism either. It's just in view of the current
people who live here or something.
Yeah, I I would I would recommend just to wrap your head around
this and I'll tell you, but maybe you should read the Wikipedia
on it. Um so so national conservatism has kind of reared its
ugly head. And a few months ago I was arguing that there is no
conservative philosophy
Uh why so mad? Because I'm just saying what the why the religion
is not spread
Right? That's why Judaism is so small. Why it's so insular. It's
why they're able to resist like assimilation in a bunch of different
places.
It's like It's It's literally key to the character of the people
and how they've like lived in the world and their
And then you're like, "But actually there's a small group of
them who don't do that." Yeah, no [__]
That's why I'm annoyed, cuz you're you're trying to undercut
like an actually totally acceptable and understandable point
to go, "Um actually, I think technically um they're not all like
this."
And that's kind of annoying. And everybody who knows you is annoyed
when you do this. But continue. >> that Donald Trump and
his sycophants fall under. That That's what I argued several
months ago. But if you look at national conservatism, if you
check out the Wikipedia, um it effectively says that they are
a political block that is kind of obsessed with the current demographics
of a nation-state and think that like culture, sovereignty,
um religion,
um ethnic demographics, all that They're kind of obsessed with
maintaining and stabilizing that character. And as an example,
they would cite the Polish politicians in Poland. They would
cite Viktor Orbán out of Hungary. And I think Donald Trump also
meets this criteria. >> you benefit someone for having
this philosophy unless you agree with it? Because I think that
there's extremes of
border, uh anti-sovereignty,
analysis.
Uh there's extremes that need to be guarded against. And so as
an >> an ideal job at that? Trump is No, I I I would put
it at 10.
Be- Because Like I Because like I said, I was waking up. And
so I uh I probably mixed
fulfilling my ideal of this policy versus fulfilling the ideal
of the ideology. If Donald Trump is a perfect national conservative,
national conservatism is just not my ideal. But if it's not but
you understand that if I should change his score. Yes, I already
said that. All right. I I already said that like
Okay, so you shut up and he's like, "I Listen, I Here's the chart,
but I [__] up my homework really badly."
K, hold on. Trump Trump is the ideal national conservative. He's
a 10. How are there so many 10s here? Wait. Like I don't even
think with the with the criteria he's given, I don't even
I don't even think this makes sense. Like within the column he's
he's flipped it multiple times, but I I can't make anything make
sense here.
You've got
Nikki Haley, Teddy Roosevelt, George Bush, Nick Fuentes, J.D.
Vance, and Donald Trump are all 10s in the same scale. What?
What?
You know what this is, right?
These are The 10 is I could think of this person being my dad.
I could think of this person being my emperor. That's what the
10 is, right? National conservatism That's like the emperor.
That's like the ordained one. It 10 is I could picture this person
being my
That's what That's what it is. Then the Then this scaling makes
perfect sense. It's entirely obvious. >> I should probably
bump him down to a five or six if we're working off of my ideal.
Okay. So Okay, so national conservative is like your ideal amount
of national conservatism. Um and and that relates to questions
of immigration. Um you mentioned
Um but it just seems very counterintuitive to neoconservatism.
You know? But so then these are like kind of
You're calling it an ethno-religion, which would mean it's a
rule. I mean, it's literally the primarily referenced ethno-religion
in all of human history.
When people say ethno-religion, it's almost entirely tied to
Judaism. When people think of an ethno-religion, they think of
Judaism first, second, and It's literally the entire article.
Israelites. It's It's the whole thing. But anyway, I'm going
to remove you from the thing I see in terms of chats cuz you're
annoying. So, good luck. Uh you can come back later. So, You're
fine. You can keep chatting. I just don't see you. Just because
you advocate for liberal democracy or republicanism internationally
and through soft power and military strength, doesn't mean that
you're an open borders advocate. Yeah, but No, no, no, no, no,
no. But, neocons are not open borders advocates.
Right. But, neocons are They're typically civic nationalists.
>> But, the neocons are like interventionist. They're uh
universalist when it comes to rights. They are um certainly less
particular about preserving ethnic and uh whatever heritage that
at least the professed ideology is more about spreading democracy,
spreading liberalism, that is say economic liberalism, um and
uh you know, the Bretton Woods type sh No, I I agree. I think
I think that's why they're Oh, wait. That guy came in to say
it felt anti-Semitic earlier, though. Wait, hold on. Did you
leave
If you want to say why you think it's anti-Semitic, you can go
ahead. Hold on. You actually want to talk about that? The ethno-religion
thing I'm just obviously correct on, but if you want to if you
want to actually talk about the anti-Semitism thing, if you want
to join the Discord, you can come in and explain why you think
it's anti-Semitic. Go ahead. Go ahead. Go ahead. Yeah, I'm down
for that.
Let's do Let's do a [__] conversation in Discord.
Let's go. discord.gg/jstalk.
You can hop in the voice chat. Let's do I'm really tired, by
the way, so I'll stop between the tribes. So, like the the national
conservatives view themselves as like the future of the right
wing because the neoconservatives were in power effectively.
Okay. Um just anything
anything you think's like not a joke explicitly, anything you
think like belies some actual underlying hatred towards the ethnic
group? I definitely, by the way, though, have total disdain for
Israel as a country. Like, complete and utter disdain for Israel
as a country. If you think that's anti-Semitism, well, then I've
just admitted to it and you got me. Okay? But, I have complete
and utter contempt for the state of Israel.
through the late Cold War into the early war on terror, and they
viewed them as like disastrous interventionists who did not care
about the home front. Um and the neoconservatives have earned
that reputation. Uh they've earned that reputation. But, that's
why they hate each other so much is because uh they're
the the national conservatives view the neoconservatives as hawks
in the streets and like, you know, doves in the sheets. Whereas,
you know, the uh the national conservatives are like doves in
the streets and hawks in the sheets. And so, they're opposed.
They're they're politically they're political rivals. Okay, if
they're political rivals, I I don't understand why you're Like,
I understand neocons to be against protectionism, to be uh you
know, in favor of What kind of yee-yee ass spreadsheet am I looking
at? Uh Connor basically [__] up all of his scoring
in this spreadsheet that he was using to try to like hammer out
exactly who he vote who would vote for and why. And so, Pisco,
I guess asked him to take some criteria he votes on and then
put it together and try to weight it and see how you actually
view these candidates, right? And build your ideal candidate.
Um
I think
it's uh it's obviously [__] up in a bunch of different
ways. More legal immigration, in favor of um trade deals between
different countries, in favor of greater unification among Western
uh countries and spreading democracy to other such places and
and making sure America has a a strong presence on the world
stage and is governing things across the world. That's why I'm
more aligned with neoconservatism, and I view kind of this national
conservative idea that you're introducing that you're talking
about not that you're introducing it necessarily, but that you're
talking about as kind of in favor of protectionism, in favor
of just focusing on American interests, in favor of you know,
breaking off the ties that the neoconservatives want to create.
So, it just seems like well, I mean, like for example, you have
Lincoln 10 neocon conservative and also 10 national conservative.
And it just very much feels like those ideas have a lot of um
opposing uh principles.
Well, sure, but I mean, I I also think that we're probably doing
like a vibes-based philosophy rather than systematizing the underlying
ideology. So, for instance, like neoconservatism wasn't around
when Lincoln was around, Right. but then how does he get a 10
on it? Well, we'll >> Because he's because he's geopolitically
competent to the point and he also used American interventionism
in order to impo impose republicanism on arguably a foreign rebellious
nation. Wait, so so fighting a rebellion is is interventionism?
Stamping
out rebellion, enforcing them to be republican. Is interventionism?
Absolutely. And in the sense that you Is interventionism in the
sense of like the international sense? Well, I mean, obviously
it's a domestic sense because he participated in the Civil War
then more than he did the uh the thing. Maybe it's a meme answer,
I don't know. But, like but effectively like when you think of
neoconservatives, you typically think of that like, you know,
like Uncle Sam with an AR-15 going over to Afghanistan in order
to shoot terrorists in the face. When I think of Lincoln, I think
of Lincoln looking like Uncle Sam, grabbing a musket, walking
down to Dixie and shooting slavers in the face. It feels very
spiritually
Interesting. So, so you kind of view the war in Iraq as like
an extension of the Civil War? American Civil >> Uh I view
the war in Iraq So, I think what the Civil War in the United
States and what the war in Iraq share is a antipathy towards
like uh tyranny. I see.
Okay, let's get into the let's get into the num Wait, what did
he What did he just passive-aggressively highlight again? I see.
Love my morning Connor rage bait. Okay, let's get into the let's
get into the numbers, then. Okay. Um
Obama and intelligence like raw IQ type thing. And it Yeah. Okay.
He's just a a smart guy. Obama 10, cunning 10. I even think that
he Obama's far less cunning than you're giving him credit for.
Like, he seemed a little naive in his first term, especially.
Well, uh but I I think that even you would admit that his charisma
is a 10.
Oh, yeah. I guess I'm
I guess I'm Yeah, yeah, combine political efficiency along with
charisma for the cunning rating. And then also what I would say
>> doesn't have a perfect score, though, because he [__]
up on uh passing certain legislation. He wasn't able to get Merrick
Garland through. He was kind of like a rule follower to down
to the every single second of it. >> but compare him Don't
compare him to the almighty. Compare him to the alternative,
right? There's no There's no president
No, he's saying that Obama decided to follow rules in a way that
he could have easily just not followed the rules and claimed
ignorance and won. In the same way that all of these people do.
The same way that And he's going to have like perfect execution
of policy because there's obviously going to be obstructions
in the way. The question is whether or not he can he's playing
the game to the maximum to his maximum ability. And I I think
I think Obama arguably played the game to his maximum ability.
To his personal maximum ability or some other standard? Yeah,
I'm sure he played to his personal maximum ability. But, I mean,
what what do you want to change it to? You want to change it
to an eight? Uh I would probably give him >> I just
Okay. Let's All right. All right. All right. We'll keep going.
So, neocon six cuz he got out of Iraq, I guess, and so he gets
>> Yeah. You would want him to stay in Iraq. The pullout
from Iraq was a little messy. It's a little messy, so he gets
a Yeah. Okay. Um
Constitutionally, why only a seven?
Um I would say that the the ACA uh the ACA expansion, um I have
no idea where like universal access to health care
Wait, is the Affordable Care Act
>> is like constitutionally supported. I have like no idea
how you can legally compel is like no idea where like universal
access to health care is like constitutionally supported. Uh
Wait, but it's not consti Would you say it's constitutionally
prohibited?
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. Is it constitutionally prohibited?
Why would you care if it's constitutionally like
Where Where would it be prohibited is the question. I have no
idea how you can legally compel American citizens to consume
a service. I have no idea how the [__] that's possible.
Have you Have read I think he would like transfer power once
he was no longer elected. He respected the term.
Wait, taxes? Aren't the Isn't this just
Isn't that how taxes work?
What? You consume government services based on paying your taxes.
You pay for these services.
Like, social security. Do Are you guys not forced to pay into
social security if you work? Like, does your employer not automatically
Sorry, you call it something else. What do you call it? Yeah,
social No, it's social security there, right? Okay. Okay. He
he respected the balance of power. He consulted the judiciary.
Uh so, that's why I gave him a seven. Have you read Sebelius?
That's the opinion which says why. Cuz it's um just it's just
a tax penalty. It's just like a sin tax or like it it would be
like, you know, by the way, states force you to get driver's
license in order to drive. States force you to uh you know, be
insured um you know, and to buy products sometimes. But, this
was just Oh, insurance is actually way better one. There you
go.
Just a tax. Um if you didn't have it, you had to pay a tax.
Um yeah, sure. Uh I just you know, once again, if we're if we're
getting back to constitutional originalism, I just don't Okay.
I I get it. Like, we've we've built on this like tax structure
over time. Uh but, I don't Once again, like life, liberty, pursuit
of happiness, I I just don't understand how the the state can
compel you to consume consume a service. But, that's okay. If
you want to rate him different, rate him different. I don't give
a [__] Fuentes gets a 10 on na- nation? You You wrote
that down. He's obsessed.
Yeah, two It's bad. preserving the demographics of the United
>> Yeah, that's bad. It's not good. >> Yeah, so he
should if if we're talking about my ideal because I'm a civic
nationalist, I should bump him back down to a six. Okay, he he
right now in how you view it, you would prefer Fuentes to Trump.
I would.
Why? I I think I think I think Fuentes is actually like potentially
infinitely more competent and intelligent than Trump. Yeah, why
is that a good thing if his aims are horrible, which they are?
Well, I mean, I've reflected that within the cri Hunter, Connor
be like, I just want the most dangerous psychopath. K, if Connor
is just most Give me the most dangerous psychopath I can imagine,
under what pretense did he vote against Hillary Clinton? THAT
WAS YOUR IDEAL CANDIDATE, BRO. WHAT THE [__] HUH,
HOW DID YOU EVER ADVOCATE AGAINST HILLARY CLINTON? Maybe he's
on my page, okay? Actually, give me the person who can get away
with murder. I want that person, okay? I may this may be less
than we think, okay? Cuz I'm on that page at this point. Hey,
if you if you need to give me somebody who can get away with
murder just to get me out of Pete Hegseth as Secretary of Defense,
then God willing, let it happen, okay? For the Please, please
just give me Hillary Clinton. At least she dominates somebody
who didn't leak war plans through Signal to a
Good lord.
Criteria, he's a zero on neocon, he's a zero on constitutional,
he's a zero on fiscal, he's a zero on Burke.
Hassan [__] doesn't get a zero on
Yeah, he does.
Guys are [__] arseler. He gets a zero on His
real intelligence is a three. His real cunning is a five. His
real neocon is a zero. His real constitutional is a zero. His
real social is a zero. His Why is his real constitutional a zero?
His real fiscal is Just a fiscal should just say start saying
why. For the zeros, why? That neocon thing might be a zero, >> real
national is a zero. His real Burkean is a zero. So, he gets an
eight.
Teddy Roosevelt Wait, no. Nikki Haley is your top. Nikki Haley
gets uh an eight on intelligence.
Someone should average them in there.
By the way, Connor's not updating any of this as they go along.
So, like even though he's acknowledged that all of this [__]
is wrong, he's not updating any of it cuz he put it in paint
instead of a spreadsheet. So, this is all a worthless exercise
because none of this information is being retained. Let's see
how they do. Um I'm just going to There's only two, right? Uh
I think she's the Yeah, I think she's the only woman. And Harris
and Harris Oh, there's two women, yeah. Cunning, seven. Neocon,
Like I'm telling you what actually happened here is Connor like
adjusted this after the fact to try to get these people like
to where he wanted. He wanted Haley to be his ideal candidate,
and so he gave her 10s in random places for no reason. >> And
you've given Lincoln more neocon than Nikki Haley. Interesting.
And you have a >> actually That's because of her Israel
sweeping. I think she's too Zion-con.
Are you getting Fuentes
So, Phil, how much America First are you
Um enough.
How often do you find yourself laughing and agreeing with everything
they could
Uh rarely.
30% of the time. And I would say like
That's just not true. That's just not
Bro, that's not true. I guarantee that's not true.
The only places he disagree with Nick are on Israel. Everything
else he go like oh, that's funny. That's funny. That's funny.
That's funny. Zion-con is the same thing as neocon. What's this
guy talking about? Well, also, if Zion-con is the same thing
as
uh sorry. If Zion-con is not the same thing as neocon, then where
what does Haley even believe?
Cuz yes, Zion-con and neocon are just totally overlapping categories.
It makes no sense for Nikki Haley to be below anybody here. Like
I'm trying to see who she Who could she go below?
Nobody. She is the person. She's literally like best friends
with the top donor in Israel. The top donor to American Republican
candidates, Miriam Adelson. Like she goes and spends her vacations
with Miriam Adelson.
She couldn't be more Zion-con. She couldn't be more neocon. It's
descriptively
He can describe a problem relatively descriptively. His prescriptions
always suck at.
Interesting. Like like even if he's like oh, we have an entire
generation of lost boys who are smoking weed and hanging out
with video games, and they're so socially stunted, they can't
even find girls, and the job market is terrible, or even if you
do get employed, you're underemployed, or you're not valued properly,
or you're alienated from your job, or this that the other. Even
when he's making descriptive claims, then then his prescription
is that's why you should become a Christian nationalist. And
it's like okay. All right, then. That That's not going to help
any of the things that you're complaining about.
Why is Bush not a 10 at neocon? Why is Bush a That is a good
question. Why is Bush a five at neocon? Bush is the neocon. That's
who all of us I know the neocon term from when Bush was president,
and they called them all >> All right, so my big thing
to talk about with this chart is I think that you should weigh
certain things more than other things. I would rate like adherence
to the Constitution
way more important than fiscal responsibility. I would weigh
like um neocon
that is not an important factor in my decision. I don't want
like uh I I It just seems like these would be more comprehensible
if you Yeah, what the [__] How is Bush a 10 on the
Constitution?
Dude, what the [__] What?
How? How in the [__] world?
Bush is the reason that Trump has the power to go strike these
boats, right? Isn't it some like Iraq war that you can the president
has like control of of the president has control of some some
group and they like they could do this kind of uh strike on terrorist
groups, right? They don't need like congressional
You have like foreign policy, domestic policy. Uh I don't know.
Immigration, character. And instead they're they're kind of the
categories Well, yeah, obviously the Patriot Act is worse. Sorry,
I The Patriot Act The Patriot Act goes without saying. That's
what I originally reacted to was just the Patriot Act existing,
and it's a 10 on constitutional. But also,
like without requiring requiring Congress's approval, he's drone
striking people who are nationals of like allied countries, ostensibly
allied countries. Maybe you say Venezuela isn't allied anymore,
I don't know. are themselves like stance stances. Like neoconservatism
is itself It's not like a category of thing. It's it is an ideology.
Um and so it's a little hard for me to follow, but obviously
I think that someone who gets a zero on Constitution, why would
you ever vote for someone who you get a zero on Constitution?
>> what That's what you said to me. And that's what That's
basically the complication. Yeah, and so what And what is the
response?
Um the response is Vance is a political chameleon, and I have
to see what the
>> on Constitution. You you put him a zero.
What? I love this dangerous psychopath who never maintains his
stripes, who changes colors and and creeds all the time. I love
him so much. He's just such a cool dangerous psychopath. He's
so cool. I I I just I I'd vote for Vance cuz I want to see who
he really is. Like I just think I we should roll the dice, okay?
There's a chance he's like really cool. He could be like Teddy
Roosevelt, maybe. I don't know. I have to look at what the political
ground looks like in
Yeah, but he has a zero on Constitution.
That could change in the next two to three years.
Really? You think that he's going to be You're saying he's a
chameleon that he'll do anything?
Dude, why? Huh?
There's a chance he's just like lying to get in with Trump, and
he actually loves the Constitution, but he's willing to destroy
it with Trump just so he could get power. And that makes him
very cool in my opinion. That's like very cool, you know? So,
he's awesome. But he might develop a a loyalty to the Constitution?
Yeah. He might He might not be
Dude, dude, dude, dude, dude, dude,
Dude, he has white ass fascist. Let's
These people are only pretending to be evil. Come on, guys. They're
only pretending to be evil. They're not evil. It's just a joke.
JK. I mean, are you [__] with Kind of I'm kind of
[__] with you. Um Why? Why are you Or bec- because
at the end of the day, ideological purity or ideological adherence
to these ideologies or these ideas. Let Let's say that we change
the category. Let's say that we changed a
Let's pretend I didn't [__] this up totally. Let's
pretend I have any thoughts on this at all. Let's pretend I didn't,
you know, phone in my homework after playing Warhammer for 12
hours yesterday, just like Jstock phoned in his stream after
playing Civ for 10 hours. Let's Let's Let's pretend that I actually
put some work into this, guys, okay? Let's just pretend hypothetically
imagine I tried. Neoconservatism is just
This is This is me in high school.
Just like I know I didn't do any of my homework, and I [__]
it all up, but like could you just pass me? I Come on, man. Come
on, man. Come on, bro. This is just like my high school experience.
Yeah, I know you wanted us to do this assignment, but like you
know, I just wanted to do other stuff. What can I say? >> Um
in foreign policy. Constitutional Constitutional conservatism,
let's change it to um just constitutional loyalty. Social conservatism,
let's just change it to social policy. Fiscal, let's just change
it to fiscal policy. National, let's change it to immigration.
And then Burkean is going to be important to me, but it might
not be important to anybody else. I don't understand the Burkean
is different from some of those, but Are they Are they an incrementalist,
or are they a revolutionary?
That's what that that is. And uh you think that J.D. Vance is
an
Uh J.D. Vance got a two out of 10 on that criteria. So, he's
actually more revolutionary than Oh, sorry. I thought it was
I thought it was a seven.
So, uh the point is with J.D. Vance, uh I did say that he's a
political chameleon, and I I think that you kind of mentioned
this that you think that there's uh kind of like he's like a
black hole. He he's like a pariah in the Warhammer 40K universe.
He actually um he has no form or substance. He's kind of like
a demon. Pisco Pisco's pulling up missy comments, okay? It's
so over for Connor. He doesn't even know it. Pisco pulling up
missy comments to mock Connor the whole time.
Dude, this is so Dude.
Does Connor realize he's like Pisco's personal lolcow at this
point? I hope he does.
I don't I don't get why he why he does this to himself. He's
like a pariah in the Warhammer 40K universe. He actually um he
has no form or substance. He's kind of like a demon.
Now he's Now No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no. There's no way he's trying to couch it legitimately just
intentionally for my sake. I feel like this is a joke because
he watched my stream or watched Queen Man's stream, and he's
trying to undercut the reference. He's going to go I just want
to throw a 40K in there reference in there to [__]
people or something. There's no way he's just doing a 40K reference
for fun because he like thinks it's the best way to explain this
to Pisco when Pisco has no idea about 40K at all. There's no
shot >> that you think that there's kind of like he's like
a black hole. He's like a pariah in the Warhammer 40K universe.
He actually has no form or substance. He's kind of like a demon.
And I agree with that. But at the same time, the these
you can't predict anything about this person. And you know what
I think what about a person I can't predict anything about who's
shown a propensity for lying and changing their stripes at the
drop of a hat? MAKE THAT MAN PRESIDENT. MAKE THAT MAN PRESIDENT
NOW. I need that guy in the Oval Office. demons that we're evaluating
the W you know versus the W you don't. What we're realistically
evaluating them for is how they're going to achieve and wield
power. And I think that Vance, because his cunning is lower,
because I put him at a seven, but realistically he can be so
off-putting you might even bump him down to a six. Because he's
so personally off-putting, he does not command the cult of personality
of Donald Trump. And so I think he's going to be a much he's
going to have to broker power much more than Trump ever did.
And so he could he might not be a constitutionalist at all, but
he could rhetorically pay
If J.D. Vance, okay, there's two options with J.D. Vance. One
is he really is that off-putting. He's really that aw shucks,
that kind of guy. That's that's possible. Maybe that's even like
a more likely thing, okay?
I think the less likely but scarier outcome is that he puts that
aw shucks thing on to get votes, to be the everyman, to be the
like kind of lovable goober for people. I don't I don't necessarily
think that's like true. But I could see it.
But there's this other element that tells me that that goober,
that like
like weird goober, probably isn't a 40-year-old millionaire vice
president.
Probably not. Like probably not. Probably there's something like
of substance there that is pretty scary beyond just the teal
funding. I think. There's there's like a chance, okay? But either
of those options are bad. If it's if he's just a goober, this
whole conversation's moot, okay? He's going to have a DeSantis-like
fall off. He'll go he'll go into the 2028 primary and he'll have
to respond to something like Fuentes is saying and he'll get
totally mogged on aura alone and he'll there will be nothing
there, okay? He'll just he'll just lose entirely.
Not not in terms of Nick trying to get elected. I'm saying like
Nick will be commenting on a and he'll just get he'll just rip
him apart, okay? It'll be over. >> Constitution. But that
would be because he's actually power brokering with actual constitutional
conservatives in order to win their vote. So whereas if Newsom
was like, "Yeah, [__] the Second Amendment. I'm going
to ban every single gun in existence." then I'd be like, "Okay,
actually Newsom is scoring lower." So. This is kind of what it
sounds like to me.
If you ask me probabilistically, sorry, this is actually important.
If you ask me probabilistically,
do I think Vance in the vacuum caused by Donald Trump, that he's
going to moderate to the extent that he's politically viable
versus do you think Newsom is going to become so progressive
and woke in the next four years that he's going to be politically
unviable? If I was a betting man, I actually think that Vance
is not going to moderate enough and Newsom is probably going
to moderate enough to
So and that's reflected in the current scores, by the way. Newsom
I have at 52, Vance I have down at 41.
Got it, but there's there's a margin here that needs to be considered.
I can I can I say it? Um what it sounds like to me, and this
isn't a perfect
it sounds like you're saying this is the kind of way it's perceived
by me. Not that I think um that these the administration is specifically
the people I'm referencing. So just keep that in mind. I'm not
saying that they're literally like this, this is like the kind
of feeling I get. It would be someone's like, "Well, you
Heinrich Himmler is going to be a lot more of a party official.
He's going to be a lot more reasonable than um Goebbels and so
given between you know Goebbels and Himmler, yeah, like obviously
Himmler has more cunning. He might actually be him doing it in
a way that like um you know Göring isn't. Göring is this national
hero and he's going to have more ability to you know move around
the party and do bad things." It's just like and when the option
is those people or um I don't know, John Adams or something like
the the comparison or even just like Barack Obama. It's like
you're considering all of these different like extraneous things
and like hang on, the problem is these are reptiles who get zero
for Constitution, right? Like like obviously, yes, you've the
thing you the thing you described is like the downside. You Connor
describes like Connor be like, "Yeah, this guy's like kind of
a lying
child-eating, child-consuming,
lunatic, okay? But they might have to power broker with other
people. That makes them like somebody I want having ultimate
authority over the country. That makes them somebody I want in
the Oval Office. Yes, maybe they are like the worst human being.
Yeah, maybe listen.
Listen, okay? Ted Bundy you can say what you want about him,
but he was charismatic and realistically he if he's in the Oval
Office, he's going to do a lot of coalition building.
What are you what are you talking about?
What are you talking about? That's the problem. Right? Like the
problem is this guy's head is missing. But you're talking about
like Wait, wait, wait, wait, we don't have to vote for like the
the most transparently
unprincipled psychopath for president? Wait, we that's not a
requirement. I thought we had to pick him. It was like that guy
or or actually the second incarnation of Chairman Mao. It's either
J.D. Vance or Chairman Mao in Connor's mind and he's going to
pick Vance. It's like, "Okay, but I know Mao is bad, but listen,
J.D. Vance, he could be anything. He could be a boat."
how he has a bruise on his arm and how he could stand to lose
a few pounds. But but wait a second, Connor, he's missing his
head. This this patient is this is a cadaver. It's not even a
person. It's it's missing its head. We we need to find the head.
And you're like, "Oh well, I mean you know, I guess he we could
like give him an Advil or something." That's what it feels like
to >> But this is but but this is where I think that you
guys aren't going to get what you want, okay? So I think we could
probably agree on this historically if you'll indulge me a second.
Oh god, it's story time. It's story time again. Oh no. >> construction
in the post-American Civil War. I'd love to respond to that,
but what I'm actually going to do instead is tell a totally disconnected
story for no reason and then I'm going to forget what I was talking
about and I'm going to fall asleep, okay? So buckle in,
you're here while I gish gallop. >> should have continued,
right? And the in the sense of the heresy probably
So people weren't barred after the Civil War and this cuz cuz
they're required so we can't bar totally amoral psychopaths from
the Oval Office because they're
I honestly honestly there's probably like an an actual thing
that he could have said there that wouldn't be
I'm I'm going to I've watched enough of the content.
The best bit with Connor, if you're like debating Connor, you
need to take like some really like you need to take some niche
like child's game and then do like the lore from it, okay? This
actually this actually um
Hold on.
This is just like when Gary Oak said this thing to Ash Ketchum.
This is actually just like when Professor Oak said like this
thing to Ash's mom. This is actually just like when Pikachu said,
"Pika P." This is You should be doing You should be doing these
like references with just like very childlike games to mock him.
Maybe like Animal Crossing lore. I actually don't know the lore
of many games. So but you should find something totally to just
learn the lore of just so you can make fun of Connor. Just so
you can make fun of Connor being like the biggest on planet Earth.
One thing a president is supposed to do is swear to preserve
and protect the Constitution of the United States. That's the
number one thing and you've given them zeros. So I'm not saying
that I expect there to be a truth and reconciliation or charges.
The reason I was bringing that up was to show you how bizarre
it is to hear
Connor will Connor be like, "I can't vote for Hasan [__]
because he supports terrorist groups and that's anti-American."
And then Connor will also be like, "Yes, this guy gets a zero
in Constitution, but here's why I'd vote for him."
What? The are you talking about? You're talking about these what
I consider much more minor, less important points. You'd be like
discovering that J.D. Vance and Donald Trump were literal lobster
people, right? If you found that out and you and someone were
to tell you, "Yeah, you know, Vance, he's got really good economic
policy." and you'd just be like, "But wait a second, why are
you talking about that? He's a lobster." And like everyone would
call you weird like for saying like, "Oh yeah, well I'm considering
also the fact that he's a Burkean conservative at a two out of
zero." And you're like, "But hang on, he's a lobster person."
Oh, I just realized it's all I hate it. I hate it so much. It's
all downstream of him sweeping for Destiny, isn't it? This is
just the Destiny position, right? Oh well, yeah, he's like bad.
He like definitely did like some crimes. But listen, you got
to take what you got. You got to work with what you got. There's
like you sometimes you just got to accept the bad and and like
take the good. This is like downstream of that.
Like other people have disqualifying criteria. Connor has to
issue all disqualifying criteria except except
terrorism support, which Nick Fuentes has done, by the way. Just
to be clear, Nick Fuentes has supported every terrorist group
that exists in the Middle East and is against Israel that Hasan
[__] has supported. Nick Fuentes has supported all
of those people and yet Nick Fuentes somehow gets a 36 while
Hasan [__] gets a zero
in his initial chart.
Very cool. Very on the ball, Connor. Very cool.
Yeah, the yes. And I
Really? Dude, did Did not see his whole thing with the beepers?
Have you not seen his whole thing with the Beepers where he's
like, "I can't even support you guys anymore. You're getting
ripped by Israel so badly."
He's talking to like Hezbollah.
It's It's obvious. Yes, he like supports all those groups that
are against Israel. I not only hear you. Now, maybe Hassan might
support them taking shots at like American boats. He might be
like, "Oh, American foreign policy is bad." And And Nick is just
like, "Oh, Israeli foreign policy is bad." Maybe there's like
a slight difference there, but still every terrorist group that
that Hassan supported I think Nick has supported in some way
or another. Except maybe 9/11 and the Taliban.
I don't think Nick would support that. Uh but I recognize that
in a a moral universe Yes. Hold on. Yes, the guy who said something
like, "Sorry to disappoint you guys, but the American Empire
won." Yes, exactly.
Didn't think I'd have to admit it, but it happened. Yes, exactly.
>> Like like a more just universe, this should just be
disqualifying. I should be able to just say, "Because he said
that he would enable Donald Trump in the false electors scheme,
and because he's become such a Trump brown-noser, and because
he's enabled a disastrous agenda that has probably cost the international
economy trillions of dollars and killed hundreds of thousands
of people hundreds of thousands of people unnecessarily, um he
should just be instantaneously disqualified." I understand that.
Uh however, what I'm saying is that I am moving I have moved
into probably in the past 5 years 10 years into the lesser of
two evil calculi. Like like that's just the way that I I I told
you. I told you. I told you it's
Oh, this guy's like an open book. This guy's so easy to read.
This guy's so So the other day he hated hated that J.D. Vance
works with the Now he wants to vote for him. No, no, no, no,
no. Connor is just like, "No, no, no. I think that's like what
we can get, and so we have to work with what we what's It's just
downstream. Once you start justifying things like this, you just
there's no stop. There's no end. It's forever. This is you forever,
Connor. You have no principles forever now.
You give them up, and you can't get them back. It sucks. >> I don't
know. I don't know. I'm not saying that I don't take this view
like Prime Kai where you don't do harm reduction when it comes
to voting. I'm just asking what even conceivable that Gavin Newsom,
who you by the way you said Mark Kelly easy question. I would
take Mark Kelly over um I should probably throw Mark Kelly on
my spreadsheet. But like let's stick with Gavin who you're less
sure about. What does Gavin have that even compares to the fact
that J.D. is a lobster person that would be like, "Hmm, it's
plausible that Gavin Newsom." Like I understand if it turns out
that Gavin Newsom actually is the reincarnation of Mao or something
or of like Okay, I'll I'll hear you out. If if there's actually
evidence like there is I I told you as Oh, I just said this before,
too. He just sees it as like I I get the Dude, what the I didn't
Did I hear that before? Maybe I heard that and just didn't process
that I'd heard it. Cuz I was saying the second incarnation, the
reincarnation of Chairman Mao.
And now apparently he said that. Maybe I'm just remembering that
he said that.
Or I'm Or I'm actually pondering this orb, okay? One of the two.
By the way, one such person I think is Fuentes. I think that
Trump is preferable to Fuentes. And I'm just being honest with
you right there. Yeah, but are are you um are you saying that
he's preferable to Fuentes because he's incompetent? Because
he's Yeah, I think that because he would execute less of his
nefarious agenda. To be real with you, I
Oh, man. I legitimately think
Oh, we'll see. We'll see.
There's a chance Fuentes would be like
Immigration would be worse, way worse.
But a lot of other things would not be as bad. I don't think
Fuentes would be drone striking boats. I really don't. I don't
I can't see it.
Is there anyone worse than Nick? Uh it depends on what you mean.
Oh, also Israel would be defunded overnight. So, but in terms
of just America only
Right? In terms of America only
I'm not sure I'm not sure which one would end up worse. >> Corruption
um in some ways it is really really bad by itself and horrible,
right? But it also um oddly sometimes has the quality I'm trying
to think of
It just depends on what you want to hold against him, right?
Like uh it depends on what you want to hold against him. If you
think all of his beliefs that he's ever professed are sincere,
including the ones from when he was like 20, then no, you couldn't
you couldn't have him there under any
But Nick would probably drone Bibi. Maybe. This is one of those
things where it's like [__] versus Fuentes.
Are either of them going to not work within the international
order?
I don't know.
You want to know what the real like black pill would be? Is that
I don't know that Fuentes would be more competent than Trump.
There's like a certain mechanic to working within government.
Like you you you you get something you get a way of working with
other people, and you learn how to how to like come to group
decisions, how to work with other people and talk to them. And
the problem with somebody like Trump, and I think it would be
the same problem with Fuentes that makes them seem more incompetent
than they actually probably even are, is that they're totally
narcissistic. They're totally like intro
like not introverted, but um they're totally self-motivated or
[__] They only care about themselves. They're They're
narcissists. They can't see anybody else. They don't know how
to negotiate with other people. They don't know how to not get
their way, and that's what makes them totally incompetent as
leaders. So, I don't even know that that Nick would be like more
or more competent than Trump. I could just be worse, to be honest.
I think there's there's like a real problem with the cult of
personality person becoming president that is just on them having
a cult of personality. Like they are such a narcissist that they
cannot work with any coalition, and things grind to a halt, and
the only things they push through are things that they have to
break the system to push through. Yeah, exactly. Exactly. Yeah,
this is exactly what I'm saying, Porter Beller. Like I I was
hypothesizing for a second, and then I'm like, "Wait, no, this
is like core personality trait that means you basically can't
be president. You basically can't really be involved in politics."
You You have to break things. So, you deny the great man theory
of history? No. I don't, but every one of those points things
are like significantly worse than they are
I also think that usually it's somebody seizing power and then
rewriting history, right? Like odds are that Caesar was not as
cool or as awesome as he led everybody to believe, but he was
weaving a legend, right? That's what I think that's what you
have to accept at some point. If you want to be the great man,
you have to start actually rewriting history. You have to become
very good at That's like your number one thing. Every single
person makes mistakes. Every single person is fallible. The people
who are in history as the great men are the ones who are the
best at erasing their bad history.
Or rewriting it. Caesar did probably one of the biggest genocides
in in world history, right?
But nobody really talks about the Holocaust he perpetrated on
all of France, basically. The The person who should be most beloved
by the Brits is actually Julius Caesar, okay? Despite him coming
over there and doing some fairly awful over in Britain, that
isn't even close to what he did in France, okay? He devastated
France, all right? He enslaved like all of France. He went He
conquered all of France, and then he enslaved all of it, okay?
>> of preventing um certain ideological excesses that I
think Visigoths? No, no, no, the Gauls. The
It's like Modern-day Gaul was in was more or less in France.
Most of it. Fuentes would be prone to in a way that I think is
fairly >> yeah, I actually Well, you know, this was just
a This This was a stab in the dark. Like this whole spreadsheet
is a stab in the Oh, also Augustus attempted to wipe out the
Germanic tribes. Um okay, Augustus attempted to wipe out the
Germanic tribes, and then every single person after him also
attempted Every single emperor after also attempted to wipe out
the Germanic tribes, okay?
Dude, that's literally the requirement of being emperor of Rome
is you're going to take a couple legions out to the German frontier,
and you're going to kill as many people as you can hoping you
get through them. And guess what? You never get through them
all. You never No matter how much you try to pillage, it doesn't
matter cuz the ultimate rapers and pillagers are the Germans,
and they're going to they're going to feed it back to you. Might
take three, 400 years, but they're going to feed it back to you
in spades, all right? They'll be back.
They try to wipe the Germans out, Germans are back. They try
to wipe the Germans out, Germans come back. It just can't be
done, okay? It cannot be done. >> Um but the reason why
it was a stab in the dark is because I think anybody who listened
to our conversation, I don't know if it was yesterday or the
day before, um but anybody who listened to that conversation
was probably pretty
Roman history is J Stacks 40K. It might be. And the reason why
they were unsatisfied is actually because of what you said, which
is like schizophrenic Goldilocks. Like you have like 20 criteria,
but we can't nail down exactly where they are, and you just are
saying like this one's too hot, this one's too cold, this one's
too hot, this one's too cold, this one's too hot, this one's
too cold, but it doesn't seem to be systematized in a way that
you can actually perceive things. And I think that's that's kind
of what happens when you're you're you know, you're kind of like
vibes based. But what I'm trying to do Hold on. I actually probably
do need the context of what Connor was just saying without the
pause and without the rant about Rome in the middle of the game.
Yeah, but are are you um are you saying that he's preferable
to Fuentes because he's incompetent? Because he's Yeah, I think
that because he would execute less of his nefarious agenda. I
think that the the corruption
in some ways it is really really bad by itself and horrible,
right? But it also um oddly sometimes has the quality of preventing
um certain ideological excesses that I think Fuentes would be
prone to in a way that I think is fairly I actually Well, you
know, this was just a This was a stab in the dark. Like this
whole spreadsheet is a stab in the dark. Um the reason why it
was a stab in the dark is because I think anybody who listened
to our conversation, I don't know if it was yesterday or the
day before, um but anybody who listened to that conversation
was probably pretty unsatisfied. And the reason why they were
unsatisfied is actually because of what you said, which is like
schizophrenic Goldilocks. Like you have like 20 criteria, but
we can't nail down exactly where they are, and you just are saying
like this one's too hot, this one's too cold, this one's too
hot, this one's too cold, this one's too hot, this one's too
cold, but it doesn't seem to be systematized in a way that you
can actually perceive things. And I think that's that's kind
of what happens when you're you're you know, you're kind of like
vibes based. But what I'm trying to do is rather than just pull
Okay, just wanted to make sure there was
uh criticism of Connor. >> was P.F. Young, but the whole
P.F. Young thing would be like, "God, well, this is just how
I feel." You know? Like that's I'm not going to do that. Um I'm
trying to that systematizing it. And so the stuff Yeah, but I'm
not I'm not I'm appreciate your effort. Hold on. The The criticism
isn't that you
isn't that you The criticism is that you push back based on how
you feel. So, you can say, "Oh, I'm not going to be like P.F.
Young and just say this is how I feel." No, you already did that
twice, actually. You You that twice, and then you showed up a
third time today, and you're trying to rewrite the chart in real
time to justify how you feel. So, you can say, "I'm not just
trying to say that's how I feel." But, you have done that in
effect by arguing this totally tenaciously for the past couple
days. Just admit that you want to argue how you feel. You just
haven't figured out how to lie to yourself well enough. That's
or lie to Pisco well enough.
Dude, what the [__] are you talking about? Uh-oh.
It just says straight rage chat. Uh-oh.
Can Connor explain how he reveres Mark Kelly for being principled
and and saying "Fuck you" to the government, but the only reason
he has the opportunity to do that is because of J.D. Vance, who
Connor would support? Very interesting question. that you're
that you're doing this and that you're trying to Yeah, but you're
just saying that there's probably better ways to do the system
than there should be. There should be disqualifiers. I don't
even think it's necessarily disqualification. I just think that
the the they should be weighed differently. That's first and
foremost. And and second, I I just fundamentally I don't I think
that any kind of way any principle basis of your stated values
that finds a way to put a quantitative um shell around what you're
talking about will, if it's rational obviously conclude that
voting for Newsom is preferable than J.D. Vance on current information.
In the same way, if it were Trump Like that. But, I don't even
think it's Uh I'll tell you what I'm doing consciously, subconsciously,
I don't
You're just saying it's how you feel over and over again. Just
accept that you're saying it's how you feel. I'm not going to
be like I'm not going to be like that other crazy guy, PF Young.
I'm not going to be like him. I'm saying that's just how I feel.
But, I just Listen, it might be conscious, it might be subconscious.
What's another name for your subconscious? The things you don't
like consciously understand at the moment. Yeah, like how you
feel about things. You don't always understand that, right? I
am uncomfortable, like deeply uncomfortable, with the way that
the left is currently conducting itself. And that doesn't mean
that the right isn't worse. The the right right Ask me, I'll
So, I'm deeply uncomfortable
Hey, I I'm trying to rant here, okay? >> way that Mondani
has been sanitized. I'm deeply uncomfortable with the way that
Hasan [__] has been sanitized. I'm deeply uncomfortable
with the way that liberals and capitalist progressives um have
just said, "Oh, they're they're just like they're just sock dems.
They're just like cute. They're just ooh ooh. They're just kind
of I eat. Don't worry about it." And so, what I'm doing is I'm
reserving judgment until I take my fraction of political power
and cast it in a vote. And I'm saying, "I am worried about these
things that you are doing. I can't compel you to shift my way
politically and view the world that the way that I do it, but
I'm just telling you I'm not signing up for your So, so, if you
want me to sign up
Just to be clear
this is what Hasan [__] did. And every single person
around Pisco absolutely
destroy like flayed him alive for it, right? This is exactly
what
Hasan [__] did. Hey, you are not representing me
on Israel at all. I understand that nobody else is, but like
as long as you're off of my values, I don't I'm not making a
decision right now. I'm holding back, okay? What did Connor say
about Maybe Connor was totally cool with Hasan [__]
not supporting Kamala Harris. Maybe he's totally fine with it.
Maybe. for your team. Gavin Newsom better stay a [__]
out of it. Gavin
If Dems were pro-gun, Connor would switch in a heartbeat. No.
No, no, no. Connor has said that he would, but he doesn't have
principles. If they became pro-gun, I he might perform the he
might do a performance of switching to Dems, but what I'm telling
you is if they were pro-gun in the first place, no, he would
just have different criteria that Dems needed to fulfill. He
would just lie.
It's He just he's he sticks these things there, and he like thinks
it's a way of like getting people to advocate, but he doesn't
understand Pisco like has these principles like grounded out.
He like he he believes what he believes. And Connor needs to
like change those principles. He can't go, "I feel like I don't
want to vote for you." And Pisco will go, "Oh, well, I'll change
what I believe
That's not going to work. But, he's been doing that. That's been
the whole conversation so far. >> Newsom better not become
the reincarnation of Mao Zedong. He better not do a podcast with
Hasan [__] And if he does a podcast with Hasan [__]
he better give him >> Who cares? Who cares?
It's it's literally more disqualifying to have an appearance
with Hasan [__] than it is to say you will not follow
the Supreme Court of the United States on their decisions.
Actually, listen. You did a a podcast with Hasan [__]
You laughed. You took a scree You took like a picture at dinner
with him. Disgusting. I'll never vote for you. Oh, you just don't
want to follow the Supreme Supreme Court or the Constitution.
You want to shut down all government services. Well, you're super
cute, and I don't know what you actually believe in, but I'll
vote for you. I'll totally vote for you. Let's go.
You ever argue with actual people? You want to hop in the Discord
and argue about something? Let's go.
I offered to argue all the time. Literally anytime somebody disagrees
with me, I say, "Hop in the Discord. Let's go."
They just never do it.
I would love to.
But, you can't Would you JD JD Vance has podcast with some of
the worst people. What the [__] I was going to say.
Do you Do you think But, do you think that's a viable axis of
criticism? A viable axis of criticism? To to interact with people
who are If you like, you can go to YouTube, go to the Rational
Kitty House channel, and look for any of my debates with this
where I say a lot of these things to their face.
So much so that he had to leave my Discord because he was getting
If J.D. Vance does a podcast with Nick Fuentes or Richard Spencer
or name a far-right guy the the If he doesn't challenge them,
if he just gives them a hand job, yeah. But, not but not the
interaction itself. No, but but That's what I'm saying. I'm saying
that Yes, I have other streamers on or I used to have other streamers
on all the time. For some reason, there's like a community that's
like totally like a big community of people threatening to dox
those who participate in my community. So, right now, little
difficult, okay? But, usually, when we don't have a huge specter
of like some totally psycho psychopathic millionaire trying to
dox everybody around me, uh things are quite rosy. We debate
people all the time. on the left. But, do you understand it on
the right? Why don't you understand it on the left? But, but
no, I understand it, but JD The difference is JD is giving hand
jobs to horrible people all the time. And it's not And I'm saying
if Gavin Newsom wants my vote, he better not give hand jobs to
horrible people. Well, first of all, JD is a horrible person.
So, just put that put that down in your book right away. Like,
JD is a despicable human being himself. Um I think that JD Vance
uh I'm going to say something controversial, and I'm going to
make you agree. JD Vance is a worse person than Hasan [__]
is or not. No. That is a I don't understand how you even begin
to draw that conclusion. You just read the history of socialism
and communism in the 20th century. Ah.
Oh, boy. It's it's actually Dude, it's actually that simple.
All you have to do is you have to understand that the decommodification
of basic human needs, workers owning the means of production,
and also the emancipation of the working class has been used
as a historical pre like emancipating the working class from
the horrors of capitalism has been used as a
Do you spout nonsense, or do people not like you cuz you're intelligent?
Um Oh, it's probably uh it's a split between three different
columns, and I don't know the ratios, and I have personal biases
on what the ratios are. Well, I say three. I don't know if it's
three. I just said three for some reason. So, at least two. Column
one would be I just don't reach out to people enough, and there
are people who would come on stream. I think I reached out to
Lav the other day, and she's like, "Yeah, come on." And then
I just never followed up. So, I Listen, there are I need to reach
out better. Uh there's one part which is I stopped doing my open
room as much. So, I used to have an open room where streamers
would just drop in. I stopped doing that as much, so people fell
out of the habit. And then number three, there's a totally psychopathic
millionaire trying to dox anybody who participates in my community.
So, between these three, there's like some ratio of the three
that has disrupted collabs recently. But, I don't know exactly
what the ratio is. I can control two of them. Right? And I will
control two of them. But, I can't control the third one. So,
we'll see. If people start coming back slowly over time, you'll
know that it was the first two that were the big difference makers.
If they don't come back, then you know it's the third one that's
a big difference maker. political control by the worst people
in human history in order to commit crimes that are on par with
Adolf Hitler. That's all you have to understand. And and if you
don't understand that, then just pick up a history book. It's
actually like not art. So, if you sanitize, in my opinion, authoritarian
communism stop Pisco needs to just get it on the record that
the Holocaust is significantly less important in human history
than the Great Leap Forward. In terms of genocides, the Great
Leap Forward is significantly more evil than the Holocaust. Please,
Pisco, just get Connor to put that on the record for us so he
can justify his opinions right now. Please, please, please. Just
I know like Pisco doesn't like ped posting. He doesn't want to
get Connor to put that on the record. I need Connor to put that
on the record. Please, Connor, tell me that the Holocaust is
not uniquely evil. The Holocaust was not a unique evil in human
history. The actually, the Great Leap Forward was far worse.
And realistically, we we treat like they're bad, but why would
you hate Nick Fuentes? Wouldn't you hate Hasan [__]
Cuz this is what he believes, 100%. It's what he believes.
But, he doesn't he won't actually say it. He won't say the whole
thing cuz he's total he's a total zogbot
on top of being whatever this is. >> Stalinist Russia,
Maoist China, uh Pol Potian uh Khmer Cambodia, and uh to some
extent, some of the crimes that the Vietnamese uh committed under
Ho Chi Minh. If you evaluate those crimes that they committed,
they committed some of the most like insane crimes in all of
human history. And so, if you try to sanitize that
He's saying it. He's saying everything. Pisco, just get him to
say it. Come on, man. IT'D BE SO FUNNY. normalize that, reintroduce
it back into public public conversation, I think you're the biggest
piece of [__] in modern politics. Let let even debate
it and talk about it. Let let them sanitizing terrorism. To to
even debate it and talk about it. To so like What do you mean
debate it and talk about it? I'm happy to debate it and talk
about it. What What are you talking about? So, you're like if
Gavin Newsom has Hasan on to talk about Democratic politics,
and like the election that's coming up, let's say he's a nominee,
you would say, "Oh, wow. Now I have to vote for J.D. Vance cuz
you talked to Hasan on his podcast." No, it would depend on the
Seems like not many in chat know what the Great Leap Forward
is. Can you explain? Sure. The Great Leap Forward was a period
in Chinese history
where they tried to do uh they tried to industrialize China.
Great Leap Forward. They tried to industrialize China, and they
they took some policies they they put some policies into effect
in terms of their agriculture that led to a massive famine and
killed off a huge number of people.
So, Great Leap Forward is the
it it's basically just what you call the the period of time where
they put this five-year plan into place. And I think what they
did was they What did they kill all the They killed all of the
starlings or something, right? All the starlings, all the sparrows
that eat the the bugs, and then they had locusts. And the locusts
took everything over and killed all the the plants. Sparrows,
right? Sparrows. Yeah, yeah, yeah. So, they killed all the the
sparrows, and Yeah. So, when you have total authoritarian control
of a country and you can just do like mass policy, this is the
issue. I think
Man, this is one of the issues.
The only way you seize authoritarian control, maybe this is like
a core of Yarvin's belief that I've never really teased out of
it, but it seems like I just had sort of a thought. It seems
like the real issue with these groups is when they seize authoritarian
control, they have this ideology that they're totally religious
about, right? They're total zealots and they put it everywhere.
If you had somebody seize control, oh my god, maybe I can justify
voting for J.D. Vance. If you if you had somebody in total authoritarian
control who didn't have those like totally zealous beliefs, who
was willing to do experiments in different places, then like,
okay, maybe maybe you could like make something work. But but
the only people who've ever seized authoritarian control are
people who have like total ideological commitment,
Is the whole point of my Well, hold on. It's not the whole point
because you can't have liberalism under a dictator,
But you you need like a you this is the philosopher king thing,
I guess, right? This would just be the the philosopher
That we need philosopher kings, right? You need the guy who who's
willing to try different things, who's willing to be humble and
understand they could be wrong, but also has total authoritarian
control and is intelligent in how they meticulously go about
things.
Sure you can, that's bonapartism. Damn.
And Napoleon I think I was cool. They did him bad They did him
dirty in that latest movie.
I man, I kind of I remember driving with Connor on some things.
Dude, there's one point, okay, where I totally agree with Connor.
He has the exact correct opinion, okay? And that is
If Hollywood wants movies to do well, just make a white guy who's
awesome and get him to do awesome sh
Billion-dollar movie idea, okay? Awesome white guy who does awesome
things, billion-dollar movie idea. Awesome white guy who's torn
down and totally in every possible way, not a billion-dollar
movie idea. Stop tearing down all the greatest white dudes in
history. That's not cool. That's not funny. That's not interesting.
It's not good movie, okay? Actually just take a white dude and
make them awesome and then everybody likes it. It's called John
Wick. It's called every great movie ever, okay? It's called every
great movie ever. Plus Morgan Freeman for for the prison movie.
God damn it.
Shawshank. Shawshank. God damn
Okay, hold on. Hold on. Hold on. I am the B top 200.
We go to the top 250, okay? Shawshank, you could argue that the
white guy isn't the main character, maybe not. Awesome white
dude, awesome white dude, awesome white dude. Never watched 12
Angry Men. Awesome white dudes doing awesome sh Huh. Awesome
white dude doing awesome Actually, still another awesome white
dude doing awesome sh Awesome white dudes doing awesome sh Awesome
white dudes doing awesome sh with awesome black dude in there.
Um The Good, the Bad, this is a spaghetti western? Yeah. Awesome
white dude doing awesome sh Awesome white dudes doing awesome
sh Awesome white dude doing awesome sh Awesome white or awesome
schizophrenic white dudes doing awesome sh Awesome white dudes
doing awesome sh Awesome white dudes doing awesome sh It's like
it's just the exact formula, okay? I'm sorry, it's the exact
formula.
It That's just That's what it is. How many of these movies are
just like totally the awesome guy who does awesome
How many of these movies? Thing The Lord of the Rings is white
dudes is weird since there's elves, orcs, hobbits and everything.
Okay, hold on. You're right. You're right. Hold on. I was I was
actually really out of line there. It's not necessarily awesome
white dudes doing awesome sh So, let's look for all of the people
of different ethnicities here. White, white, white. Don't know
about this guy. White, white, white, white, white, white, white,
white, white, white.
White, white. Okay, so I Hold on. Wait. Wait. Wait. I'm waiting
for the counters. Wait, what? Wait, what?
Sorry, this is the one place where I can be like
what do you call it? Like provocative and funny and we don't
have to actually take it seriously cuz it's like white.
Like I don't know why I said that. Cuz it's like it's jokes.
It's just It's like movies. It's not reality, okay? I don't think
I don't think this is like It's like one of those edgy takes
where it's sort of right. What the real take is, okay? I'll give
you the real take. Cuz I I I like saying it that way. I like
giving really hyperbolic versions of my actual takes cuz it's
just funny and then people will actually argue with you. It's
basically I try not to do it as much cuz it's the It's like the
the Destiny technique, you know? But it's
The real take is, if you're so concerned with DEI and not putting
white people in like a position of power or having to show whiteness
like being evil and being torn down in some way, if that's your
concern, you're going to tell terrible stories. It's like a heuristic,
okay? If that's your concern, you're going to tell terrible stories.
You're not going to be concerned about like making the best movie
you can. You're going to be concerned about conveying the right
message, right? Sometimes
what you have to understand is the greatest writers of all time
understand that they can be writing a story. They can have their
plot points. They can have their plan and suddenly inspiration
will strike in the middle of the story and they have to change
something. They have to change something, right? They do have
to change Wait, what? Hold on. What's my category?
Just chatting? What? Oh, anyway. So,
what was I saying? Oh, yeah, greatest writers, you have to change
something. When you're trying to deliver a message about how
like the the white person's bad or like something like this.
When you're when you're trying to drive an ideological message,
it's very very very very difficult to make the best movie you
can, okay? You will ignore the signs of when things should change
to keep whatever message you wanted to deliver in the first place.
When realistically like people on I I think the greatest directors,
the greatest writers in history understand that there are organic
directions these things can take that make way more
Are you just sweeping for Napoleon? No, I'm saying Napoleon was
about tearing this guy down and making him look gay. And it would
be a better movie if they just made him look awesome. If they
told the story about how he like totally defied odds and was
awesome and like ruled this country with an iron fist and charisma
and took everything within his like within his vision. That would
be a [__] cool movie. That would be a great movie,
right? That would be an awesome movie. You could even include
the downfall about him losing in the end. But it's like him versus
the world and he he almost wins and then he loses. But instead,
they make it him versus the world and then he's like being totally
manipulated by a woman in in
And it's like, oh wait, what? Like why?
Wait, why? Anyway, imagine Gladiator of Russell Crowe is some
gay Exactly. Imagine Gladiator if if the emperor's sister instead
of [__] Russell Crowe made him sit in the corner
and watch her somebody else, okay? Not a good movie. Not a good
movie. All right? It's
Just make them cool. Just make them cool, man.
God. I'm sure there's movies with like black people that could
work the exact same way, by the way. Um I I it they don't actually
have to be white. It's like just a It's basically just that when
they're not white, Hollywood was like Basically, when you pick
non-white stars, there was like a financial disincentive to do
it. The movies wouldn't do as well, for better or worse, okay?
For better or worse, yeah, Django is literally that. I love Django.
Django's an awesome movie. Yeah, exactly. Just make them a badass.
Make them a badass that transcends race,
That's all you got to do.
Imagine Training Day if Denzel was some
Yes, although he's not a hero. He's an anti-hero, but yes. He's
an awesome
Dude, imagine Django if instead of that hot woman at the end
with the huge abs. Sorry, not Django. Imagine Training Day, but
instead of that hot ass black woman with the huge abs at the
end of the movie, right? Imagine if or Latina woman. Latina woman,
right? Imagine if Denzel Washington was watching her get [__]
by the white dude, okay?
Not a good movie.
DON'T MAKE THEM How hard is that? How hard is that? You want
to tell a really cool story about a Okay, go to TV. You can do
a TV series that's really powerful and subverts expectations,
okay? But don't make a movie about it. That's it.
The one black movie is about slavery? Uh we we also went to Training
Day. Training Day is awesome. There's definitely other movies,
too. I just don't know them off the top of my head. Um if you
The The issue is there will be really good movies like that or
there won't be as many movies like that because for a long time,
unless you had Denzel Washington
Huh. Or Morgan Freeman, you basically couldn't have like a black
headliner for a movie that did well. Oh, Blade's awesome, too.
Yeah, exactly. Now, imagine Blade, but instead of whatever the
[__] happened, he actually sits in a corner with
somebody else [__] his woman, okay? This is movie
now. This is a terrible [__] movie. You can't do
it. It doesn't work.
Straight Outta Compton? Uh Straight Outta Compton is like a biopic.
I don't think it's the same. But you I I would agree that I I
think biopics you can tell a more nuanced story cuz it's different.
It's reality, right? I don't know Napoleon's a biopic. Yeah,
I don't know.
I'm sure like I'm sure this doesn't apply all the time, okay?
Probably what I'm actually complaining about, again, I'm more
being hyperbolic. What I'm actually complaining about is that
it's like all of the movies are like this. Whereas instead of
doing like most of the movies where people are
where we've reached like critical mass, okay? I don't need I
don't need every single main character to have some weird deviancy
where they actually do like BDSM like crazy BDSM or some sh Okay?
We've reached deviancy critical mass critical mass. We don't
need it anymore. I'm good.
For the love of God. Good. Dude, I've never watched City of God.
I should probably watch this movie, I never watched this movie
before. I should probably watch that movie.
Anyway, what were we doing while we're watching these two argue?
Yeah, that's like the one thing I would agree with Connor on.
It's just like just put a awesome white dude in there that does
awesome [__]
There used to be the issue is all of the arthouse movies don't
have white dudes doing awesome [__] anymore. Oh,
also I just realized that Dev Patel has some cool arthouse movies
where he's the main character. So Indians got at least one. But
um
So you don't get any like cool movies.
You should watch Only God Forgives, the better version of Drive.
Drive's another movie where it's like actually that was a cool
white dude doing cool [__] Even though it was an
arthouse movie. You just don't get as much of that. All the like
director or all of the directors or writers who want to do like
cool like exploratory [__] they don't they're all
doing DEI [__] Or they were for the past like 15
years, maybe it's changing again.
Or on your show, uh you know you um he says, you know, I appreciate
it. I know that you guys um We're we're going to have to What
would you say? We're going to have to argue about it at the time,
but I'm just telling We'll be like, "Oh, [__] I'm
going to vote
Main character in Drive gets though. Hmm. No, he doesn't he?
He's like he's like a weirdo, total weirdo. It it's like a different
thing, okay? That guy is just Nick Fuentes, but
That guy is just like Nick Fuentes. He's like an
incel on
for JD now. I'm not No, I'm not I'm not saying I'm going to vote
for JD. It depends on what JD's doing. >> I'm like the
thing that you're saying you're like, "I'm so worried." No, this
is how crazy it is. You're like, "I'm so worried about how the
left is acting right now." And I'm like, "Okay, what are you
worried about?" He's like, "Well, Gavin Newsom might have a podcast
with JD." Like the dude had a podcast with Charlie Kirk. It's
okay. I've already said in this conversation, which is kind of
frustrating, is that the right wing in So hold on, let me describe
this maybe to make it a little bit better. The lunatics that
were fringing the right wing took over the party. They are now
2/3 of the party. And what you're saying is, "Well, ignore the
left when the left is flirting with the fringes, and don't worry
about whether or not the fringes take over the party." And I'm
trying to wake you the [__] up. I'm grabbing you
by the shoulders and I'm shaking you, okay?
Connor Connor's sitting here like, "Listen, I'm like 51/49 on
joining your normal like mids uh what do you call it? Like moderate
party? I'm like 51/49.
If you're flirting with that fringe, it goes to like 40 to 51/49
that I stick with Fuentes, okay? That's where Connor is. He's
like, "You need to do more cuz I'm like right on the edge of
walking away and voting for Nick Fuentes directly, okay?" That's
where Connor is. And Pisco's like, "Wait, that all of their beliefs
should be like totally exclusionary. You should have like no
reason you want to stick with them." But Connor's like, "No,
I believe in like most of their things, just to like slightly
lesser extremes. I'll stick with them unless you're willing to
like really change who you guys are. You guys have to basically
I'm going to create a second extreme, okay? You've got an extreme
on your left. I'm going to create a second extreme on your right
that you have to cater to now to try to push you over in my direction."
That's what he's trying to do. You know me, all right? I'm not
a perfect person. I am kind of irrational with some things. I
am a little bit crazy. I do like to splurge out on Twitch and
YouTube politics, but I think overall you think that I'm probably
a decent human being who's trying to figure out the world as
best I can, and I'm not a liar, okay? I'm not lying about the
way that I perceive >> think you're lying. I'm not accusing
you of lying. >> I'm trying to grab you by the shoulders
and wake you the [__] up and say, "This is serious,
and it will impact the future of American politics if socialism
and communism becomes normalized on the left. There will be people
who vote against you. Maybe I will just abstain from the top
of the ticket. But I'm saying if you continue down this path
of normalizing socialism and communism and doing apologia for
the authoritarian regimes of the 20th century, I'm not a part
of the team. I'm not a part of the coalition. I won't be a part
of it. And I'll throw rocks at you. Like like that it just is
what it is."
I'm I am fundamentally opposed to fascism, political corporatism,
and flexible authoritarianism as a political philosophy because
I think it's terrible. I am fundamentally opposed to socialism
and communism because material conditions don't exist in which
socialism can exist, which means necessarily you will have to
institute an authoritarian government in order to impose these
things, which is going to repeat the horrors of the 20th century.
I'm not interested in this political project, and any sane person
shouldn't be interested in that political project either. Nor
would they be cozying up to the people who are interested in
that
Like man, dude, if you uh I just don't understand why
you need authoritarianism when the core belief of democratic
socialism is we need to do this democratically. We need to go
as far as we can in term in terms of social safety nets democratically.
It's like the entire idea, the entire purpose, the entire point.
Uh From the Southside donated $10 to say Destiny raised a whole
crop of politics streamers whose only real politics is lefties
bad and Hasan bad. These aren't serious people. Correct. Yeah.
If I granted this, it would only be in the context in which you
were proposing I think to vote for one one of those such people,
these
people. Um but in a election with Newsom, what you're saying
is cuz JD Vance is that guy. He is the guy.
You got like the most neoliberal people in the world who are
like the leaders of the party. The Gavin Newsom is super [__]
neoliberal, right? He he's extremely neoliberal. Like he is he's
not like some progressive, some socialist. He's a [__]
neolib, okay? He is a neolib, died-in-the-wool neolib.
And and Connor's over here like, "That's Chairman Mao. I think
that's Chairman Mao over there. Who is JD Vance? No, he's not
Goebbels. No, he's not Goebbels. He's like uh he's like Teddy
Roosevelt, actually." who is a danger, and he is the representation
of a kind of awful form of authoritarian politics backed by some
of the worst, most craven, and disgusting uh interests that have
ever existed on planet Earth. But you're saying not if it's between
Pisco's just letting Rose was 17 type up a a storm in his Twitch
chat. I I get the feeling that maybe Twitch is his Twitch mods
are not on the ball cuz every one of his normal mods is a DJ.
I do not think they would allow Rose 17 to keep typing up a a
storm in that chat if they were aware. between him and be >> It's
between him and Gavin Newsom if he like talks to a a communist
nicely. Uh depends on the math. It depends on how we weight the
math. I I'm reserving the right to do the math. I'm I think that
you're letting your
I'm not I'm not going to just say it's my feelings.
Uh here's like a totally logical statement, a logical question
for you, Connor. Well, I'm going to wait until I do this math
correctly, okay? I'm going to wait until I can cope my way into
a justifying this correctly, all right? Eventually, he's like
he is going to be all 10,000
monkeys on 10,000 typewriters, okay? He's just going to keep
repeating this until eventually he beats Pisco. He's he's decided
that he will attempt randomness, okay? Is his tactic. He's he'll
adopt randomness as his go-to, okay? He's going to keep trying
different iterations until he can beat Pisco. Someday, I'm sure,
with absolutely no thought put in, I'll beat you. I'll get you
one day, Pisco. I'll keep redoing these numbers over and over
again, and I'll get you one time. >> your vibes and optics.
You want to be This is what I think. And you tell me if I'm wrong.
I don't I don't think you're lying. I think you're deluding yourself
a little bit. And I think that you're trying to justify
ultimately your identity as the last sane Republican and the
maximal hater of Hasan and communism. But it doesn't really make
In my thought? Sure. It makes sense in a descriptive sense. I
don't think I'm self-aware enough to know whether or not that's
true. Uh I'm just fighting for what I think is true. Uh I would
say that if I was bringing up a criticism of you, uh I think
that because you are friends with leftists, you run a podcast
with a leftist, you are dating Are you still with Joe?
>> Isn't Joe a socialist?
Why does this matter? I don't think she had to do with that.
Because I think you have a blind
blind spot because you believe these people are good people.
You think they're well-intended. And and and they're Is BB Poison
listening to this? BB Poison, you hear right now? Can you check
Discord? >> part of your coalition because they'll vote
the right way. But I I think you have a blind spot for them.
Be because you don't view socialism as bad as I you don't You
don't view socialism as bad as fascism, so you're willing to
tolerate good
in your life and in your professional sphere. And if anybody
says, "Hey, I view fascism and socialism as like ideologies that
are effectively two sides of the same coin," you can be dismissive
of it because you know good people, and the good people are going
to vote with you. And arguably, there are a larger part of
the neoconservatives and the center-right liberals who are going
to like come your way might be statistically less uh than the
socialists and communists.
I like that Connor has made no points, right? He just makes no
points.
It's a
He just makes no points. Um I suspect you have some bias because
here's like people you know who have that ideology.
Okay, sure. So bias bias is what fuzzes and ruins and and sets
off course your points, your principles, everything everything
you think, right? Bias affects the way you think. And so you're
basically saying, "I suspect that you have this broken thinking
model. You're you're not thinking about this correctly because
of a bias."
Okay. You should be able to explain what that bias is. Right
now, the bias is I think that you can have socialist values,
parts of socialist values, without necessarily believing that
you would need to go to full-blown authoritarianism to progress
to communism. I think that exists. I think that wasn't that maybe
maybe that's not included in Marx. Possibly not. But I think
that that exists, and we we really believe that.
And you need to convince me that against that. You need to go
after that belief. Because if you just sit here beating up on
Chairman Mao all day, I don't defend Chairman Mao. Nobody cares
about Chairman Mao. I don't give a [__] about Chairman
Mao. Maybe Hasan does. Hasan cares about his little red book
or whatever. I don't give a [__] okay?
But I don't care about Mao. I just think you could have some
social safety nets and do so in a democratic fashion.
Please stop pretending that me believing that is the same as
saying, "Oh, we need our version of Chairman Mao."
And also, for the love of God, don't pretend that Hasan liking
the communist aesthetics is the same as him wanting full-blown
authoritarianism. I uh God damn it. Hasan believes in democracy
Okay, maybe. Maybe. Amnesty will vote I I I believe that he has
deluded himself into thinking he like really ideologically drives
with the the Chinese Communist Party and stuff, and I don't think
he does at all. And I think if push ever came to shove for some
reason, he would realize that and understand it. But I don't
think push will ever come to shove. I think he is just going
to be able to LARP like that
But in the meantime, I don't think he's going to advocate for
like undoing democracy or overthrowing democracy. So, the right
way? And so effectively as a progressive liberal, you have you
have to make a choice. Because you probably can't have both.
You probably can't have a coalition of socialists and communists
and liberals and progressives and get the neocons. I think people
just mean different things by socialism than what what you think
they mean. Not I'm not saying that that's >> I think 90%
of the people who say they're socialist are actually social democrats.
They don't know what socialism is. If that's your view, that
socialism means this particular virulent horrible thing and anyone
who doesn't mean that with when they say socialism are like wrong,
why don't you just use like what they consider themselves to
be? It sounds like you're getting triggered. Because I think
they're useful idiots. They're useful idiots because they're
useful idiots. I think when I think when Bernie Sanders and AOC
and Mondani and Hasan [__] when they use socialism
in order to describe social democracy and they say, "Oh, we just
want the we just want the Scandinavian system." I don't view
that as their end goal. I view that as them being politically
pragmatic in the political scene. Yeah, but what >> They
do want people to read books. They do want people to read and
they do want people to Do you think Bernie Sanders wants a Stalinist
>> class from the oppression of capitalism. >> do
you think Bernie Sanders is a tankie?
Yeah. Yes, you said? Yeah. I I think he hides his power level.
I think if he could, he would. He just can't.
What is the basis to believe that?
Him doing apologia for Nicolas Maduro's regime or sorry, somebody
corrected me in your chat the previous time. Uh who was the guy
before before Maduro?
Um who was it? Hugo Chavez.
Chavez. So, him doing apologia for the Chavez regime, him doing
a
Uh you do realize Hasan is a He wants I mean, listen. I think
Hasan is a I just don't know if he wants to overthrow
Like I just that's it. I I don't know if he actually wants to
overthrow democracy. I don't think he'll advocate for it. I don't
think there's any solid socialist coalition through which he
can gain the power to advocate for it. I think there is like
a million miles of leeway between the current Democratic Party
as it exists and anything close to what Hasan's like even his
stated possible ideals. Like even his what you could say is his
hidden power level before that becomes a reality that he could
shape. Right? I think you have a thousand miles of leeway there
that you could totally like walk a hundred miles down that track
to get more socialist to get more social safety nets in America
and you wouldn't even come anywhere near Hasan being able to
overthrow that government or have any effect in overthrowing
that government. Right? But on the right wing, that's not the
case. In the right wing, you're literally there. You're literally
like a mile away from fascism.
Maybe not quite a mile. Maybe a couple miles, but still, you're
like right That's the problem. No, he can't do anything. So,
the people who feel the need to argue re worse
are worse?
He can't do anything, so the people who feel the need to argue
are worse.
I don't know what you're saying.
Um you can join the Discord if you want. You want to join the
Discord? You can join the Discord.
Okay. >> Bernie or traveling to Soviet Union and doing
apology in the '60s and '70s, him being boys with Cuba. Yeah,
I I I think I think he's a socialist apologist. I think he doesn't
want to get murdered.
You want to talk about Hasan doing apologia for China and I don't
agree with apologia for China. I think that's stupid and wrong.
>> Yeah, that was wild, by the way. Trump and the Republicans
do it all the time.
Trump and Republicans are [__] pieces of [__]
What was wrong with Chavez paying for social safety nets with
nationalized companies? It's based. I don't know exactly what
happened in Venezuela with Chavez, to be honest with you. I I
know that their economy crashed when the oil market dropped,
right? I'm arguing for them to be less pieces of [__]
And then then they're on all fours when it comes to apologia
for despotic regimes, including by the way Islamic fundamentalist
regimes, regimes where it's monarchies and there's no rights.
So, like you can do this little thing, but you voted for people
and you will vote for people who